I'm Sandra he's lemon like the fruit  tangerine and lemon they're trained  assassins they're both a little bit on  edge they're Brothers they're twins yeah  I'm not so sure they're twins they're  Partners they're like husband and wife  they want my lemon because you're sour  no one likes lemons spy looks mate lemon  meringue pie the last time you ate a  lemon meringue pie lemon drizzle cake  I'm sorry are you talking about lemons  they bicker between each other the  energy and Chemistry Between Brian Terry  Henry and Aaron Taylor Johnson uh was  immediate Brian brings the fire every  day the minute we met each other it was  already like oh we instantly know  exactly where we're going it's really so  much fun man you're on your Bachelor  though congrats mate